Resuelve el siguiente problema de forma gráfica,
Abby y Ben hicieron entregas a domicilio
el pasado fin de semana.
Juntos ganaron 50 dólares
y Abby ganó 10 dólares más que Ben.
¿Cuánto ganó cada uno de ellos?
Establezcamos algunas variables aquí,
sea...
sea "A"
las ganancias de Abby,
"A" es ganancias
de Abby
y sea "B"
las ganancias
de Ben...
ganancias
de Ben.
Y nos dan cierta información de estas ganancias,
nos dicen que juntos ganaron 50 dólares,
¿cómo lo ponemos matemáticamente?
Bueno, matemáticamente podemos decir que
las ganancias de Abby, "A",
más las ganancias de Ben "B"
es igual a 50,
las ganancias de ambos sumadas
son 50 dólares.
También nos dicen,
Abby ganó 10 dólares más que Ben,
¿cómo lo ponemos matemáticamente?
Las ganancias de Abby
son igual a las ganancias de Ben
más 10 dólares,
Abby ganó 10 dólares más que Ben.
Tenemos aquí un sistema
de dos ecuaciones con dos incógnitas y nos preguntan,
¿cuánto ganó cada uno de ellos?
¿cuánto ganó cada quien?
Y nos piden resolverlo gráficamente,
hay varias maneras de resolver esto,
pero vamos a hacerlo como nos lo piden...
déjame dibujar unos ejes aquí,
el problema se resuelve en el primer cuadrante
pues ninguna de las ganancias puede ser negativa.
Y déjame definir el eje vertical
como el eje de Abby
o el eje de las ganancias de Abby
y el eje horizontal lo voy a definir
como el eje de Ben,
el eje de las ganancias de Ben.
Voy a graficar
cada una de estas dos ecuaciones.
Voy a escribir esta ecuación
de la forma pendiente ordenada,
te va a parecer un poco extraña
pero si va a estar en la forma pendiente-ordenada.
Entonces la voy a reescribir aquí,
"A" más "B" es igual a 50,
ahora resto "B" ambos lados,
entonces restamos "B" del lado izquierdo,
restamos "B" del lado derecho,
¿y del lado izquierdo qué tenemos?
Tenemos que "A" es igual a "-B"
más 50,
observa entonces
que cuando "B" es igual a 0,
"A"
es igual a 50,
es decir, nuestro intersección con "A",
normalmente la llamamos intersección con "B"
es 50, ubiquémosla,
10, 20, 30, 40,
50...
aquí la tenemos.
Si Ben ganó 0 dólares, entonces
Abby tuvo que haber ganado 50 dólares,
basados en esta restricción,
aquí lo tenemos,
así es que sabemos que este
es un punto en la línea
y también sabemos
que la pendiente es -1,
"B" como la he puesto aquí
es la variable independiente
y este coeficiente que corresponde
a la pendiente es -1.
Otra manera de ver esto es,
si "A" hizo 0 dólares,
entonces "B"
tuvo que hacer 50 dólares.
Esto lo vemos también
de esta ecuación,
si Abby no hizo ganancias,
entonces Ben hizo 50 dólares,
entonces tenemos,
10, 20, 30, 40, 50...
así que estas son
dos situaciones
y cualquier punto entre ellos
va a satisfacer esta restricción,
déjame conectar los puntos
y esta recta es debido a esta restricción,
debido a que juntos
ganaron
50 dólares.
Consideremos ahora la segunda,
Abby ganó 10 dólares más que Ben,
es esta ecuación de aquí
que ya está en la forma pendiente-ordenada,
si Ben hizo 0 dólares,
Abby hizo 10 dólares,
aquí lo tenemos,
nuestra pendiente es 1,
podemos seguir así,
si Ben hizo 10 dólares,
Abby hizo 20 dólares,
si Ben hizo 20 dólares,
Abby hizo 30 dólares,
si Ben hizo...
Bueno, ya lo tenemos,
ya tenemos la tendencia de la recta
e inclusive aparece ya
el punto de intersección,
así que de manera visual
graficamos las dos restricciones,
juntos ganaron 50 dólares,
es esta línea en magenta,
Abby ganó 10 dólares más que Ben,
es la restricción por esta línea verde
y parece que el punto de intersección
corresponde a Ben ganando 20 dólares...
déjame etiquetar esto,
10, 20, 30...
así que el punto de intersección corresponde
a una ganancia de Ben de 20
y Abby ganando
10, 20, 30 dólares...
Abby ganando 30 dólares...
Así que de manera visual hemos obtenido que
"A" es igual a 30 y "B" es igual a 20,
verifiquemos esto.
Veamos que las ganancias que obtuvimos para
Abby y Ben satisfacen ambas restricciones.
Así, la primera restricción es que Abby y Ben,
juntos ganaron 50 dólares,
más 20 es 50,
se cumple esta primera restricción,
la segunda restricción es que Abby
ganó 10 dólares más que Ben
o que Abby ganó lo que ganó Ben
más 10 dólares,
aquí lo vemos, Abby está ganando
10 dólares más que Ben,
así que también se cumple
a segunda restricción,
solo tenemos dos restricciones
que se cumplen ambas,
así que esta es nuestra solución,
Abby gana 30 dólares y Ben 20.